[Music]
where's my second case of lacroix
i must have looked baffled as i
delivered 246
worth of groceries to an office manager
on market street in san francisco
i
was fully out of breath
i just climbed up five flights of stairs
carrying a good 40 pounds of groceries
and what i get is not a thank you
but an accusation
where's my damn lacroix
what she didn't know was that as i was
biking over to her office i almost got
into a car accident
the mercedes adjacent to me swerved into
my lane and to dodge him i had to hit
the curb
i was ultimately okay
but the unfortunate victim of that
journey
was that second case of lacroix
had i been seriously injured
i would have been compensated
nothing
isn't it so funny in america if you are
an employee you fully expect your
employers to compensate you in two parts
wages and benefits of which one of the
largest parts of that is healthcare
but if you are a contractor
like i was at that moment
everything goes out the window
my name is joshua and i've dedicated my
career to building geek platforms at
uber and doordash in fact i led the
driver pricing team at uber so how much
workers are compensated is bread and
butter to my everyday
and yet
i hear so many stories filled with
anguish and frustration
from gig workers every day
so to understand the issue better
i signed up to be an instacart shopper
i traded my laptop for a shopping cart
and a bike you can check out my cool
setup right here
and in this role i realized just how
hard the job was
i wasn't paid nearly enough to live in a
tier 1 city like san francisco
i was on the hook for all performance
related expenses
and no surprise i had zero benefits
and this isn't just a problem for an
instacart shopper
or a door dash driver
twenty percent of our economy are gig
workers
that's 57 million americans
tech giants like google have more
contractors on their payroll than
full-time employees
universities are increasingly hiring
more adjunct professors where they're
not on tenure track and therefore don't
actually get more benefits
in california
we have argued back and forth on whether
contractors are employees and vice versa
and i say
prop 22 ab5 all of these bills
are red herring
let's solve the real problem here
let's decouple health care benefits from
employers
let me say this again
let's decouple health care benefits from
employers
[Applause]
right now the way our system is is a
historical accident
one company kaiser steel was astute
enough to realize after world war ii
when the government put in place wage
ceilings because we had an excess of
jobs and a shortage of workers that if
they allowed the use of the on-site
clinic as a benefit that was considered
non-inflationary
they double checked with the irs and the
irs said uh yeah yes that makes sense
and so they did that and it was a really
effective recruiting tool
and so other employers followed
and that's why employers pay for our
healthcare
and look this makes sense
in 1940s when an american stayed in one
job their whole lives
but we're now in the next century
where a worker changes jobs more than
five times before they even turn 30.
this system
no longer makes sense
why should switching jobs from driving
at gm as a factory worker tester to
driving for uber have anything to do
with your health insurance
let me confess
i'm canadian
so growing up i never thought much about
health care i never had surprise bills
a ride to the ambulance didn't cost me
my month's rent
and everything i needed from
medication to surgeries to services
were all covered
and when you have chronic illnesses like
diabetes
life-sustaining drugs like insulin costs
less than twelve dollars a pop versus
north of a hundred dollars here
all the while infant mortality rates are
lower and health expectancy is higher
and just look at how much more the u.s
spends on health care
double
double that of canada's
this past month lawmakers in california
had the rare opportunity to overhaul the
california healthcare system by
providing medical coverage for every
single resident
that bill was killed before it even made
it onto the floor
because critics said that it was
too crazy
and too expensive
well you want to talk expensive let's
talk about the current u.s healthcare
system
every single year employers pay 690
billion dollars to pay for employees
health insurance
while employees still have to pay out of
pocket for co-pays and deductibles and
if you're not in this employer employee
binary so if you're self-employed if
you're a contractor if you're in between
jobs you have to buy from a separate
exchange usually at higher rates because
it's assumed you have more health
defects when you don't just because your
pool is smaller
and on top of all of this the government
subsidizes the so you as the taxpayers
also pay into the current high-cost
low-performing u.s healthcare system
it's scatter shot it's wasteful
and some would even say
it's crazy
the center for medicaid and medicare
found that we could reduce health care
costs by 13
or 600 billion dollars a year if we
decouple health care from employers
why is that
number one it reduces the number of
middlemen and brokers in this process
all making a margin
number two
we reduce the amount of administrative
costs of which right now the us pays
four times that of canada and other
wealthy countries
so what do we do
well there's a lot of really smart
people thinking about this problem so i
don't want to be too prescriptive
but i'll leave you with two models
the first one is the ka model we've
talked about it's a single-payer
universal healthcare system that a lot
of progressives in the us are vying for
but similarly conservatives also want to
decouple the health care system from
employers they just want to create one
large health care exchange
labor laws would say that if your
employer no longer had to pay for your
benefits they need to increase your
wages to stay competitive
and in that world
what happens
everyone buys from one system it's
transparent it's open and it doesn't
matter what your worker classification
is
and that's how the netherlands does
health care
and it's actually how we as americans
think about car insurance
you are all future leaders in fact some
of you are running companies right
now you want to do right by your workers
but you also want to maximize profit
it's a conflict that anyone operating a
business that uses contractors will have
to face until we decouple health care
from employers because doing so will not
only increase job mobility
and reduce the burden on businesses to
think about this but ultimately it'll
spur innovation in america
right now if you have a really great
idea the reason you're not pursuing it
should not be because you're afraid
you're going to lose your health
insurance
the current system is creating friction
to entrepreneurship
we're always afraid of the next bubble
we had the internet bubble in the 2000s
the housing and credit crisis in 2008
we're currently in a student debt crisis
but what happens when a fifth of the u.s
economy has a rainy day
and no safety net to fall back on
imagine yourself or your friends or your
family biking delivering your groceries
and then out of nowhere a car bee lines
you to the curb
one medical bill
one emergency room visit
will push you to the brink of financial
ruin
this is the reality for 57 million
americans
and that number is only increasing
while health outcomes are decreasing
decoupling health care from employers
is not crazy
it's common sense
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]